hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all the
major problems of the world so to help
you on your journey today I'm going to
talk about the seven ways smart people
work less and get more done number one
is creative schedule successful people
for the most part have a schedule when
you have a schedule and you know what
you're going to get done that day it's
easier to stick with it and plan your
big things out so what's really
important what I find really helpful is
once a quarter I do a big audit of my
life of my business where am i spending
my time where am I getting the most
value from through my actions map to the
big things that I'm trying to create for
myself and so my big goal is I want to
get a million subscribers on YouTube as
an example it's one of my goals how do I
do that and are my actions mapping to
that consistently so once a week I have
a youtube day I'm researching I'm trying
to better understand the algorithm I'm
trying to update my thumbnails and
titles trying to research a new story
ideas new potential videos that we can
put out and so I'm constantly adjusting
my schedule to map to achieving those
big goals so if you know what you're
going to do you wake up every day with a
schedule that is on point and helping
guide you towards you a big picture
you're much more likely to get it done
[Music]
number two is batch similar tasks
together this one really saves my life
it saves so much time out of my schedule
or anything that you're doing multiple
times per day do once per day multiple
times per week do once per week most of
times for months she wants per month the
more you can do that the more success
you'll have it getting more stuff done
so as an example for making these
youtube videos I will make most of the
videos once a month so I come in here
it's a Wednesday afternoon when I'm
filming and we'll spend the whole day
making YouTube videos and I'll batch
them out for the entire month we'll film
between 60 and 80 different videos in
one sitting all day long because one I'm
in the mindset I'm in the mode we have
to worry about setup takedown
also me being able to be comfortable in
front of the camera share my story have
energy although that stuff really works
where if you're switching between tasks
constantly it's easy to fall off you
know if you're in writing mode I
remember being writing mode for my book
and I'm writing researching an introvert
mode don't want to talk to anybody -
then prepare for a call that's coming up
you know that half hour to an hour
before the call I'm not being as
productive I'm researching who that
person is I'm getting nervous about the
call and what's happening and so I find
it really hard to switch between paths
if I'm going to do an introvert
creative-writing day I spend the whole
day doing that Wednesdays I make my
youtube videos Thursday is my
public-facing day so I'll do interviews
and podcast and radio shows and you know
guest appearances and other people's
YouTube channels and phone calls and
meetings I mean my extrovert mode I'll
put my hoodie on and I go from one
meeting to the next to the next to next
to next back to back to back to back to
back and it really helps me stay in that
same energy and get more stuff done and
so batch similar tasks together to help
you be more productive
[Music]
number three is bring on a team you
cannot do everything on your own as an
entrepreneur at the start I get it maybe
yes you're trying to do everything
because you don't have the resources yet
to build but as soon as you can afford
it as soon as you can think of how you
can bring other people on board it's so
worth it because you have genius level
talent at something and yet usually that
thing that you're so great at you're
only spending 10% of your time on and
90% of it depends on all the other stuff
that's involved in running the business
the more you can get rid of those things
and give them to other people who love
doing it even if it's hiring somebody
for one hour a day which is what I did
with my first tire in my business it
alleviates some of the pressure to allow
you to focus on what you are great at if
you want to go far you have to go with
the team to start looking at who is
around you that you can bring on board
to take some of those tasks off your
plate you could focus on what you are
genius level talent at hey i'm john
sonmez from simpleprogrammer.com
touch the keyboard this is one of those
things that I have found has really
helped me to be more productive because
if I just put my fingers on the keyboard
if I just sit down and type up my
computer I'll instantly type in their
facebook.com or Gmail com
so always before I start anything before
I go to the computer before I open up my
laptop I think to myself when I say what
am I trying to accomplish what am I
trying to do and by doing that it stops
me from wasting a lot of time and just a
little bit of five minutes here five
minutes there that you spend browsing
the internet or doing something or
distracting yourself can can lead to a
lot of procrastination and can prevent
you from getting things done so quick
tip to remember just remember before you
sit down to do any work before you do
anything know exactly what it is that
you're supposed to do and then when you
unlock your computer put your fingers on
the keyboard or you sit down in your
chair that's what you start doing and
you don't just go to some social media
site all right number five is eliminate
so I mentioned at the top how I love
doing a quarterly audit of my schedule
it's so so so so important because you
often find things that you should not be
doing anymore so as an example I have a
mastermind group and I used to keep
minutes of every meeting I thought that
was the professional thing to do if I
was adding a lot of value I keep track
of what everybody was doing what they
said they were going to do and report
back and send them the email every month
after the meeting and say hey here's
what we talked about here the minute
notes one month I got too busy and I
wasn't able to get it up and what
happened was nothing nobody cared and so
the next month as a test I didn't send a
minute notes out again either and nobody
cared nobody emailed me nobody called me
nobody wrote for me nobody asked where
they were so here was doing this service
that I thought was really valuable it
was the quality value add for my
customers and nobody actually cared
about it and so ever since then I
stopped doing minute notes there are
things that you are doing in your day to
day calendar your day to day schedules
that you may think is adding value but
really isn't and if you can eliminate
those take that chunk of time out of
your schedule then you can focus on
higher priorities
[Music]
number six is automate so after I've
eliminated all the stuff that I don't
need to do the next thing I looked at
before bringing on a team is actually
automating if there's anything that I do
on a consistent basis using the computer
maybe it's over and over and over
repetitive tasks I immediately start to
think how can I automate this how can I
find a software tool to help me do this
or how can I hire somebody to build a
program for me to solve this problem so
as an example using YouTube there's a
great tool called tubebuddy that I'm the
highest paying member of I've upgraded
my account twice to pay them extra money
I'm not affiliate with them in any way
but I love them because they allow you
to automate a lot of your YouTube
processes so as an example YouTube added
a new feature called
end screens where you can in the last 20
seconds of your video add some new
features in to link to the video
subscribe to your newsletter subscribe
to your channel
all that fun stuff but I already had
3,000 videos that didn't have these end
screens and going in one by one by one
by one would cause a real problem so two
buddy had that program and whatever and
paying them 80 bucks a month or a
hundred bucks a month or 50 bucks a
month whatever it is makes so much sense
because I can update 3,000 videos at a
time and so always look to eliminate
first automate next before you move on
to bringing somebody on board and number
7 is do work that you love you are way
more productive you are way more
creative you create much better output
when you're doing work that you love if
you are doing the work that you look
down and it's 8:00 in the morning you
look up and it's suddenly 1 o'clock in
the afternoon you look back down you
look back up at 6 o'clock at night when
you're doing work that you love you're
going to have a much better output than
when you're doing work that you hate you
know that work that you hate you
struggle through it you try to find ways
to avoid it you force yourself to do
it's not going to be very good and it
takes way way way longer than somebody
who loves it and it's not just about
skill somebody who loves it might be
better skill they can get it done faster
but if you had equal skill level they'll
still get it done faster because they
love the process when you love it you
want to spend time doing it and it goes
much quicker than if you don't love it
and it feels like a chore so those are
the seven ways that smart people work
less and get more done I'd love to know
which one did you guys like the most
what are you going to immediately apply
maybe to your life in your business
after watching this video did I miss an
8 9 10 that you want to add in as well
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find it I also want to
give a quick shout-out to Jelena of
throve Scott thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and the fun interview we did on
your youtube channel as well
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm glad you like the book
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon